ladies and gentlemen welcome to Tim
Dylan show I'm here of the opening of
The Comedy Mothership in Austin Texas
and I wanted to borrow a studio
and my agents at CAA were like you have
to
call
your friend down there
and borrow his Studio I think they meant
Joe Rogan but I have another friend down
here that I absolutely love and he's one
of the greatest broadcasters of all time
and uh it's very exciting to be with him
and I'm sure that they're all fine at
CAA I'm sure you'll love this what would
be wrong with this
please welcome my friend who needs no
introduction the great Alex Jones
Tim amazing you did an incredible job so
the rest of the folks at the mothership
last night Joe looks like she's in a
time machine he's getting younger while
you and I get older yes amazing hanging
out with you guys and Roseanne Barr last
night yeah with me yeah me you and
Roseanne look like we're going the wrong
way and Joe looks like he's going the
right way the van looks pretty good
actually
yes compared to me well you know
Roseanne is she's there's there's she's
animated by a force of Life yes which is
good uh and me me and you struggle with
that but you're a sexy guy I appreciate
it truth is we're getting married in
Vegas next week we're we're getting
married in Vegas and everyone will
support that I believe right well I mean
it's not a joke we're getting married
it's going to be you and I Joe had a
menage as well last night it's the Royal
web yes we were both very out of shape
and he talked to us about that uh but
this is gonna be the royal wedding [__]
Meghan Markle and that autistic lizard
this is gonna be the one
um but it's amazing to be here thank you
for letting me use your studio
thank you there you go somebody wrote
that Alex three-fourths of Mount
Rushmore
that is pretty hilarious
me you and Roseanne Barr the Dream Team
the family
um and I put you guys up I said you're
really starting to grow up when you
realize your parents are just people and
you and Roseanne uh are my are my
parents
um but I was watching uh you know so
much stuff is said about you that
because you're so banned you can't
respond to and this is like the craziest
thing because I'll watch something and
I'll go Alex should be on his show
refuting that and I know you are but
it's not anywhere that anybody can see
and one of the things that I watched was
at January 6th I watched you tell the
protesters to not enter the capital to
be peaceful you said we're not antifa
we're not going to burn things down this
is what they want we're not going to
give it to them that has never been
played on mainstream media they have
never played any video footage of you
telling protesters to not breach the cat
Capital which is literally what happened
and I want to play that clip in a minute
speaking to you off there A lot of
things are now
coming uh out about January 6th to
change the picture a little bit from
what people thought was that was just a
little bit just a little bit
and I want to know if you can illustrate
some of that for us because I know that
this directly impacts you it affects you
um uh you were there you were there to
protest what you felt was a a sham
election anomalies yes right election
anomalies you were not there to breach
the capital and you were telling your
supporters to not reach the capital but
there were people in the crowd
encouraging violent Behavior agitating
leading and now it's coming out that
some of those people are from an
interesting origin
absolutely and I mean it's a giant story
and it's bigger than January 6th for
Trump or any of that with he loved him
or anything you know I've got a
love-hate relationship with him it's
that we had a million people with the
ellipse for his rally on the six then
they said Alex lead a March down there
well the hundreds of thousands already
under the capitol before I ever got in
the middle of it I said how do I lead
this so I was telling the crowd be
peaceful it's a big crowd but all other
rallies been peaceful and we get down
there and tear gas is already getting
fired and all this stuff's happening and
I didn't know that out of a million
people and hundreds of thousands with
the capital that a few hundred attack
policemen broke in and I was up there
saying stop it don't go in and then the
Wall Street Journal the New York Times
by that afternoon said Alex Jones was
there leading the attack saying attack
the capital even though we had the video
but it was only on infowars.com right it
was only on bandop video no one else
outside of our footage could see that
and know that since then it's got it on
Twitter and gotten tens of millions of
views of us they're getting huge amounts
of people that have been the doors have
been opened once they broke through
waving people back and keeping people
from going in then I got subpoenaed I
got uh deposed with the January 6
committee uh they were trying to indict
me they did arrest Owen Troyer and my
camera guy
San Mateo that were there with me being
totally peaceful yeah
but I was too well known I was the guy
up there loud saying don't go in
but they were with me so the feds when
they arrested them indicted them and
they're still facing trial uh our guys
have done a plea Market yes their trials
are coming up they said Owen Destroyer
broke into the capital and attacked
people right it's all he was with me he
was trying to stop it right so so when
you see them filing in court things like
saying the Loch Ness monster you know is
is is is our president or the Easter
Bunny you know is real you're like it's
next level when you're experiencing
things that are totally fraudulent but
because you're banned on all the major
platforms you can't respond they have a
blank check so censorship isn't just
about silencing people you can then
steal their identity right and you can
then say whatever you want in their
voice or take things out of context and
that's what's so dangerous about
censorship but now we have Matt tabi and
the Twitter follows a great job Elon
Musk and all of it coming out the
agencies and governments and big Tech
with media we're working in coordination
to surveill what people are saying and
have been censoring millions of people
for years including during the Trump
Administration so that's all coming out
I know you you were telling me before I
went live here or before we turned down
came to the show that you've got some of
those clips but this is just an amazing
moment to be alive plus they've got the
proud boys trial going on in DC and just
a few days ago it began to break they've
had Federal filings I've got copies of
we can do an overhead shot here maybe of
your guys punch it up where the feds
accidentally gave a bunch of files to
the defense with stuff like we've been
ordered to delete 300 plus files we've
been ordered to cover up they were
non-violent we've been ordered now
they're declaring today National
Security in D.C saying these are top
secret documents so they are in full
remember the Whitmer kidnapping plot
where it turned out the feds again
accidentally handed over stuff they
wanted to cover up yeah and it was them
ordering you know like these potheads to
attack Whitmer and they're like I don't
want to oh can I have money for a Big
Mac right can I have a can I have a dime
bag
and they never attacked the lady yeah
the first group got off but the second
time the judge covered it up they all
got convicted so the point is the the
same group that led the attack on
Whitmer that never happened were
intimately involved the same unit of the
FBI in January 6. that's not coming I
mean look at this these are documents
that are now being they're National
Security uh are they classified are they
just today the judge is declaring them
classified uh but this is the federal
filing so I won't show the classified
doctors I'll show the federal filing in
here uh that's now been put up by uh
a bunch of even mainstream journalists
like Julie Kelly uh it says right here
edit out they were present that the feds
were there leading the group and then it
describes in one line uh here and I
guess the crew could probably pull this
up where they say here it is
Miller's Communications with other agent
who states the agent's FBI boss assigned
to 338 items of evidence I had to
destroy why would they want to do that
destroying evidences of felony why would
they want to destroy the evidence
wouldn't they want more evidence because
they were leading it of course yeah well
and that's why they're trying to block
Tucker releasing their raw footage and
on Tuesday and you see these videos of
people opening doors allowing people in
the capital there's a video of the Q
Anon Shaman guy with the [__] hat
with the horns she's being led around
the Capitol by multiple police opening
doors and led into the center chamber
yeah and he thought he was with Q he
thought they were with him and this was
a coup right I had him on two days after
he's like no the police were with me
they let me in we're winning we're
taking over and I said no dude you've
been set up right I felt so sorry for
him now four years in prison yeah
non-violent turns out he's schizophrenic
right he was kicked out of the Navy for
being schizophrenic I've talked to his
family people to know him really nice
guy non-violent yeah and they've now
framed of schizophrenic as the leader of
a mastermind operation can we play the
clip of Alex's War where we have Alex
with a bullhorn on January 6th telling
people to not be violent because this by
the way will be the first time a lot of
people have seen this on a public
platform because it is you telling the
protesters at January 6 to not engage I
was about to say you're sticking your
neck out here because yeah the only
place until Elon muskok over Twitter
this was allowed nowhere right I mean
this is I mean obviously I don't want to
attack the capital I don't want to go to
jail what does that makes it look like
idiots right and but they're trying to
say I'm no I showed up the middle of it
was like what the hell don't go in well
I was watching it with friends at my
house and I was going I I turned to a
friend of mine I said this is [__]
absurd that there's a video of you
telling people not to attack the capital
that has never been seen to my knowledge
by anybody really and this again is you
telling people we're not antifa we don't
want to burn [__] down we don't want to
breach the capital we want to be
peaceful and make our voices heard and
it it throws the whole narrative about
you about the you know what they're
calling obviously the riot
um into question one of the most
exciting things about the New Year is
you have no idea what Adventures are in
store for you there's no better way to
prepare for 2023 by learning a new
language with Babel Babel is a language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions and if America
Falls you'll need to learn Mandarin
thanks to Babel's addictively fun and
easy bite size language lessons you can
feel confident no matter where the New
Year takes you do you speak any other
languages no I can barely speak English
I need to go to Babel right now with
Babel I'm telling you right now you
could choose from 14 different languages
they have speech recognition technology
to help you improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn Babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcast games video stories
and even live classes plus it starts it
comes with a 20 way 20-day money-back
guarantee so clearly they're confident
that you're gonna love it right now get
up to 55 off your subscription when you
go to babel.com timtim that's
babble.comtim for up to 55 off your
subscription to Babel it's language for
life I love it I use it I speak now four
languages that's 55 off it's crazy and
it's nuts beginning with aliens yet
they're they're beta testing a new app
where they will communicate with the
aliens and the balloons
done Babble and I've never seen I've
been uh conscious human being for I
don't know 25 years maybe and it's
shocking to me how quickly this stuff is
debunked now things would happen it
would take years but JFK it took years
people writing books and going to
libraries and looking up articles and
you know hurting their eyes squinting at
these little pieces of paper now within
a matter of weeks and months all of
these narratives are collapsing
and and that's what scares me I'll be
honest it does scare me that
I can't get this out anywhere obviously
I don't want to attack the capital we
wanted to protest and have a 10-day
Senate investigation I showed up tear
gas literally hit me from 200 yards away
uh people were climbing scaffolding I
saw Riot police they were attacking
police I'm like no no no don't do it
then I went to the police and I said I
know you have a loudspeaker system they
use it at night super loud like the
voice of God leave the capitol you're
not allowed to be here I went to the
police they got a captain I said it's on
video yeah it's on our uh on uh my
security had you know the cop cams the
what do you call those body cams body
camps and I say look I know you have
this loudspeaker system it's the voice
of God which is by seven o'clock at
night leave earlier martial law do not
be here I mean it's like I am us I mean
it's super [__] 5000 DB yeah and they
said and we later learned they were
their commanders would not respond for
four hours yeah so they were actually
saying give us the PA system what I was
saying yeah and they were just ordered
to stand there with their thumbs in
their asses so I don't blame the car
jobs and you know no cops died that day
one guy died of a stroke the next day
the cops did get attacked it was wrong
five citizens died have you heard that
there were suicides with the Capitol
Police yeah that's what happened that's
when the the few that died later were
suicides and one was a stroke okay but
but my issue is the attorney general the
U.S two days ago came out and said five
officers were murdered that day Tucker
Carlson's lying about the five officers
in fact I know your crew's in there guys
find that clip yeah like 15 seconds
everybody knows now that nobody died
that day but five citizens right so
Ashley Babbitt and others so they're
still that's what I'm saying they're
saying five officers died that day it's
on record they didn't like right why are
they so confident to lie like that well
because I think the reality is a lot of
people aren't paying attention a lot of
people don't have access to the
information right A lot of people aren't
going to that's what they're counting on
they're counting on that they they count
on that I was looking at it I've now
watched a lot of that footage I've
watched it on planes when they're about
to take off I've watched it when I'm in
hotel rooms on the road doing comedy and
I'm going something doesn't make sense
something's off you're telling people do
not attack it's gotten completely away
from you there are people that are being
led into this building by it looks like
uniformed Capital police a hundred or
they sent more than half the police away
for crowd control at the ellipse Mile
and halfway right by the White House
which one was giving a speech so you you
get there and there's like 50 cops yeah
for I mean it's like a football game a
championship or a basketball game
there's a million people there in the
town 100 000 of the stadium a few
hundred Riot you don't blame the whole
stadium so a few hundred did attack the
police who tear gas them the police
didn't have the numbers they needed they
got attacked they did get beat up it was
wrong people like Ray apps are ramming
signs into them saying go into the
building but he doesn't get in any
trouble and by the way he told the
January 6th commission under oath I
orchestrated the attack on the capitol
why is he not indicted but my co-host
Owens Troyer s well there's a lot of
people that behaved poorly clearly
there's a lot of people that got excited
agitated angry they they did not
psychology mob psychology they didn't
act like a responsible citizen they
didn't do what you asked them to do but
then you also have documents coming out
right now saying that this thing
potentially you know or maybe definitely
was led by
Federal informants federal agents well I
mean I I know people at the highest
levels of The Proud boys trial
and I've
I have the federal filing around here
but it yeah this is the beauty of the
universe yeah
they literally handed over the secret
files of the FBI they thought they
deleted it was an attached file and it's
all how they had informants in the proud
boys the informants said they're not
violent right that uh famous Stewart
Rhodes oath keeper Enrique tario meeting
on January 5th in the parking garage
they were talking about defending people
protecting against antifa the informants
are like there was no talk of this
they're they're saying delete the
evidence of the informants from The
Trial so they can't find a lot of
evidence of a pre-planned insurrection
like a pre-planned Riot a plea a
pre-planned interaction like they don't
have evidence of these people conspiring
to do this no okay
and so instead they cherry pick what the
informants say and edit out like 90 of
it right and then use the and then so
the judge says well we can't tell you
the informants are but here's what they
said and then it's an edited thing the
informant said right when you're there
are you feeling A vibe that something's
off something's getting away from you I
mean I mean I mean let me recount that
morning yeah I mean I'll just give you a
straight up account
I get up at 7am hungover in a suite at
the Willard Hotel I've been doing
interviews the whole night before
we ordered breakfast we drink coffee I
have sex with my wife and uh
I say I got a hangover
let's order a bottle of whiskey
so we get like a small bottle of whiskey
we drink it with coffee my wife goes I
just want to stay here I don't want to
go to this I'm exhausted I Say No baby
let's go so we walk outside the wheels
let's try with your lips and it
literally takes us an hour and a half
with like 15 security like a mosh pit to
battle through these crowds and get the
so-called VIP Lane to go in because
there's a million people outside and
forty thousand right there so there's
actually a million people at this event
the whole the ellipse the monument it's
just but only forty thousand you can get
in the actual Court not part with Secret
Service where Trump's speaking so it's
all surrounding people who can't get in
we have to fight through all that
get in I'm sitting here going damn that
Whiskey's wearing off and and so we
finally get through like a mosh pit I'm
exhausted my wife's like I want to go
home I don't like this Roger Stone's
calling me saying I don't like this I
can get to the crowd I'm going home blah
blah blah [__]
and I sit down for like three hours of
Republicans giving boring speeches and
my wife's like my feet are freezing off
honey let's just go back to the hotel
and take a hot bath uh you know and her
instincts like I have a bad feeling she
literally says let me just let's go back
to the hotel I'll suck a dick let's just
I'm being honest I mean
she goes baby let's just go eat food
which would have been hindsight been the
better plan no I mean she actually said
this yeah yeah and she's never women's
instincts like yeah I don't like this I
don't like this I want to go I don't
want to go to the Capitol not my baby
shut up and finally Trump comes out
we're watching all the Republicans
peacock behind the stage we're in the
front row all this stuff's going on
and
then the Secret Service these people
these feds where they go Mr Jones Trump
wants you to lead the March 30 minutes
before he's done we will open the gate
you will go out to Pennsylvania Avenue
lead to March and I'm sitting there and
I'm already watching crowds that are
tired of sitting around us hitting here
in trouble speaking led by antifa led by
the feds led by all this they're already
all marching down towards the Capitol
and I'm going how do I with a bullhorn
does my crew my Security's waiting
outside born right I go how do I leave
they go Trump will be there don't worry
it's all a setup not by Trump by the way
so finally they open the gate in the
front stage Trump's still speaking I'm
like Trump's like 53 feet away right
around the side I walk around and I'm in
the back of the stage and I'm with all
these Republicans and I didn't go to the
bathroom and then the feds are like no
Mr Jones you gotta go right now
meanwhile they were they were timing me
to be there right with the breach out
and I go no I gotta go to the bathroom
my wife said yeah I gotta go to the
bathroom
my wife's like I'm leaving honey my feet
are hurting it's so cold out here I
didn't know I wore the wrong shoes I go
baby you go back to the hotel I'll find
out what's going on I don't think I can
even leave this March I'll see you
she leaves uh with the lady she was with
so one of the event organizers so I go
in the bathroom take care of things get
out I'm on Pennsylvania Avenue already
like hundreds of thousands are Marching
and I go how am I supposed to leave this
I go this needs to be peaceful because
people are like if you we're gonna you
know so I get up on one of the platforms
of these big planners like 20 feet above
the roads so I got this big tree planter
and I go be peaceful this is all on
video yeah be people play that right now
because that's a video I want people to
see if we the only reason I'm taking
time is yeah yeah this is the whole I
mean I'm being honest like I drink
whiskey I bang my wife right I I you
know a a freaking Scrambler right I mean
this is like what happened yeah and then
what happens when I get there is more
insane we gotta go on Pleasant Club
let's play the clip
[Music]
you're amazing I love you let's March
around to the other side
and let's not fight the police and give
the system what they want
we are peaceful
now we won this election
and as much as I love seeing in the
Trump flags flying over this
we need to not have the confrontation
with the police they're going to make
that the story
Army on the march to the other side will
be on stage where you can speak and
occupy peacefully
tell everybody behind you march to the
other side March to the other side
order
you guys are great but the police
have caused a problem and the police are
throwing trash things we don't want to
have a kid's date here
so I love you or saving the Republic
this is beautiful but please tell
everyone to go March every other side
you always start to make a password back
is gonna speak over here
on the other side
[Music]
so this is you know again it's kind of
irrefutable you're there you're telling
people not to breach the capital you're
staying the same you're saying to stay
peaceful obviously it's not working
because there's people that are like
completely most of them can't even hear
me I mean right like the bullhorn goes
maybe 100 yards but what I'm saying is
the timeline is that you're giving me an
opportunity with your huge audience I
don't know so I'm a mile and a half from
the ellipse and I'm like how do I lead a
crowd and Trump's because we had a we
had permitted
by the Supreme Courts right here the
capital's here so in between the Supreme
Court the capitol we had a big stage and
Trump was thinking he was coming there
yeah but Trump was set up too
so I'm like BPS will be peaceful that's
another video
20 minutes before I get there then I get
there people are climbing the
scaffolding there's tear gas I see
people falling off parapits I'm like I'm
in a medieval war right and I'm like I
better get up on this pile of chairs
they weren't even unfolded like a stack
of chairs boxed you know plastic on them
for like the a month from then or a few
weeks from then for the inauguration so
I climbable time and say don't go in we
got a lot of people not to go in because
the feds had the police had opened the
doors under orders not blaming them they
were ordered to do it and and and and so
then
I go let's go the other stage so I go
around I talk to the police captains and
people I wait for like 10 minutes to
talk to them I go you got to get on your
loudspeakers you got to say get out of
the Capitol and then they wouldn't talk
they said we can't talk to you we just
and I said well what can I do they said
why don't you go up on the other side
they're trying to break the door in most
people are just standing there you know
talking but like a few people are
attacking the door they said why don't
you go up there and try to get them out
the door so I go up I say get out of
here come down it's so noisy there's all
these people blaring other bull horns
they can't hear me I looked at my crew
and I could see guys with machine guns
assault Rivals pouring in feds and I
said I need to go home to my children
let's leave right now and I and I
marched to the crowd saying leave leave
leave a lot of folks listen to me and a
lot of them left but it was then
learning in hindsight how they had 500
paramilitary police dressed as civilians
with with guns how they had hundreds of
FBI informants and now we know FBI
informants were leading the attack with
the CIA it's coming on court on the
building so we're going to find out if
these documents are ever made public
that there is proof that there is FBI
and CIA kind of collusion with people
that are on the ground leading them into
their Capital yeah if anything
Republicans are too pro-war and to Pro
State yeah but when do Republicans
attack police and Terror buildings right
it doesn't happen right uh we got
provocateured into it yeah and thank God
because I can see the timing not all the
secret service but definitely the groups
involved yeah because most of Trump's
White House is running about deep state
by then most people would resign so he
only had deepest there are people there
are people no doubt that were caught up
in the fervor and did the wrong thing
yes in the mob Madness for sure but but
we now know this is what you said that's
what's interesting right you weren't
saying that you were not directing it so
if you're not directing it and the proud
boy Oath Keepers if they don't have the
proof that they're directing it who's
directing it that's the question already
up said he said he orchestrated it who
is that
um he was there for days on all the
dozens of videos saying attack the
capital tomorrow he was there with
ramming with sign up with the police he
was commanding everybody yeah you see
him give orders like he'll be in the
crowd because they're not releasing this
footage yeah he'd be in the crowd this
was a tiger was gonna do on Tuesday but
they stopped it and he would go and like
mechanized troops would come in like
military in in Trump outfits and he
would go Red Zone attack right and they
were just like boom like like failings
Roman soldiers attack yeah and so and
they get this giant Trump sign and
ramming over the police and then Grandma
indoors the goal of this is clearly to
present the idea that anybody on that
side is completely unreasonable violent
and a terrorist well that's it and take
a John Wayne movie that are based on
real bar fights I've been a lot of bar
fights but I've been in two somebody
punches somebody it starts nobody knows
everybody starts fighting and it was
like that once you ram over the police
once they tear gas and once the crowd
kind of gets in a fight most of the
drivers trying to stop him there's a
million people or hundreds of thousands
were there million in the town they pour
in then the feds open the doors right
and so that's what happened
it's it's wild now the documents that
have been made classified who is making
them classified and they're saying
National Security
but they did this again with the Boston
Marathon bombing they put the special
administrative measures on the judge and
the attorneys nobody can really talk
about it uh even after saying that those
two brothers were not connected to any
larger terrorist threats so it wouldn't
necessarily need a national security uh
you know uh you know wall for these
documents to be behind they're now
saying that these documents cannot be
seen because somehow it would jeopardize
National Security yeah this is breaking
news tonight or whenever you're watching
this tonight
um it's coming out Thursday
so
this is a this is a big big deal
um I know people at the highest levels
of the defense team were the proud Boys
in week six still the prosecution in DC
right
and a couple days ago when the feds want
to bring forward a new Witness
they have to then bring forward the
evidence right it's supposed to be at
the start of the trial but the judge
lets them bring in whatever they want
so they get these documents uh Tuesday
night yeah and
their people go hey it says right here
there's attachments that have been put
in the trash
so that's the thing on you you trash a
photo on your phone
or a month it's in the trash right
so the FBI agent I have the documents
right here we can do it all right shot
testified that she prepared these
and in those is 300 plus documents
thousands of pages and quotes of I've
been ordered to destroy this because
they're covering their ass that's
illegal but they're saying I was watered
by my Superior Nuremberg thing doesn't
work saying falling orders right and
now I'm talking about what the documents
they've seen before the judge said
they're classified
and then we know what else was happening
they had a CI operative they had a sex
operative uh they had informants in with
the proud boys the problems are like
we're here to stop violence and we're
here to only have antifa attacks that's
all been testified to but they're
ordered in the transcripts the
interviews because the judge lets in and
tells the jury this is secret it's an
informant you don't know their name but
here's what they said but it's edited
the informant's like no they were all
against violence they're good people and
I gotta say this isn't true and then
they only get like but they did meet
with uh Stuart Rose yeah and and so you
read these things
these communications I don't think I've
listened to you for a long time I don't
think you've ever advocated political
violence whether it's on the left or the
right I've never seen you say let's kill
that Senator let's hurt somebody let's
do something violent no because that's
that's when you've lost right I mean
pull the pins matter the sword yeah and
a thousand years ago information was
more important than physical it was like
80 of it now it's like 95 right and the
Pentagon will say that uh but but
absolutely but but they want to make it
violent they want to make us violent
because that discredits us but I mean
you can read these documents for
yourself this is just the federal filing
yeah I'm just reading that when was that
filed Alex uh last night at 11 11. this
is real on the minute breaking news
this is now gone from what would be
called a conspiracy theory
into what will start to become
for lack of a better word mainstream
news except you have the former head of
the CDC saying they made the weapon
cupboards to buy a weapon no one cares
it's not being reported yeah yeah it's
the same thing yeah Miller's
Communications with other agent who
states that agent FBI boss assigned 338
items of evidence I had to destroy
that's a felony that is this damning as
anything I've really ever seen with
regard to January 6th and I've been
asked by people that are like in the
Pelican briefs they're actually scared
yeah
um
I've been asked not to say what I've
been told but it is Cia sex operatives
this is not FBI why is sex operatives
you'd think that sex operatives wouldn't
be used for January 6th you'd think
you'd get more Gruff type of like oh
they're leading the guys do you think
sex operatives are leading people
well what you have is a bunch of Macho
dudes that want to fight for Americans
yeah andiva and then and the sex
operatives are like the [__] in the
capital
yeah is that kind of well I mean it's
literally hot women yeah I don't want to
get into the whole story right but I had
them when I was in like
December in in Georgia
trying to
cover the election fraud there and I was
there with one of the leaders the proud
boys and he goes hey the super hot chick
wants to be with you hey I'm married B
I'm not stupid and
I'm sitting there and he goes no she
wants to be with you right now and I'm
like this is an infrared operation right
so I'm just at a restaurant nothing was
open then everything was still shut down
with lockdown there was a Hooters that
was open so I went over to this
restaurant
and I'm sitting there with my security
guys and in comes one of The Proud boy
leaders I'm not going to say who and
he's got this very attractive amerasian
chick with him and he starts saying hey
she wants to be with you blah blah
I later learned that individual has been
linked to the Central Intelligence
Agency and hey I was married I didn't I
was like I was drinking beer I ate a
cheeseburger I was just like yeah
sweetheart I'll see you later and I've
had that before like Trump Hotel like
two women showed the bar and they go we
want to be with you right now and I'm
like yeah I'm not Julian Assange
sweetheart yeah my dick ain't doing the
thinking here right okay so so it ain't
like I'm like starving for [__] either
so you know you know but the point is is
that is that I'm only telling these
stories not to impress people this is an
everyday occurrence right so then I get
these files and I'm like this woman's
name is that that's the woman in the
freaking Hooters trying to get in my
hotel room right so I don't need to know
oh the lawyers think it's a CIA sex off
I had him try to put her on me okay so
so so yeah Dylan that's the magnitude of
this it's it's the magnitude's coming
out Tucker was gonna do something on it
and he was stopped
I haven't talked to Tucker since then
but
I'm going to reverse engineer this I'm
not going to get into what I talked to
Tucker about yeah I've talked to other
sources and they confirmed that Rupert
Murdoch killed Tuesday the federal agent
connection the the the the ranch footage
of the feds breaking the building his
doctor has been doing a lot of work on
this where he is bringing out a lot of
stuff that is not seen anywhere else
you know absolutely he's a Trailblazer
he's a hero uh he's amazing and again my
the lawyers I know are literally dealing
with with sons of pages just like my
lawyer love him to death kind of a ding
dong uh and Dino right now here in Texas
smart you've also the like when you see
this big answer for riots when you see
the level of coordination with a group
like that the fact that
do you believe that like January 6th you
have agent provocative I mean the feds
right the Carnegie endowment the Ford
Foundation runs antiva
getting back to my Texas yeah yeah you
know the the Sandy Hook trial where the
judge already said I was guilty and all
that
I gave my lawyers all my phones there
was nothing to hide I'm like here
download it look for stuff right it's so
then my lawyer accidentally sends like a
phone so I have like a new phone every
year they send like eight nine months of
a phone to them then they put that out
publicly the Democrat judge does fine
whatever there's nothing it's just it's
not a problem nothing nothing there's an
issue
but the thing is it's a two-way door
interdimensionally that's how God works
whatever they do first Blackmagic comes
back on them ten times worse and you
call Blackmagic it's How the Universe
works when you do something nasty so now
in the Whitmer case and now in this case
the feds have given the defense
thousands of documents with the CIA and
running January 6th yeah I mean I'm not
even supposed to talk about this yet
because I'm talking the people are
scared man yeah so that's what I'm
saying like oh you put uh Alex Jones
asked his employees to get him vodka oh
he's so embarrassed now look what God
just did right your FBI agent just gave
the whole January 6th operation in that
thing and they're trying to suppress it
they are in like chickens with their
heads cut off so you see how black magic
works yeah it's big and go Alex you feel
that you like that and I'm like that but
then they themselves get a sword through
them it's not me oh you slap me now
Tyrannosaurus Rex stops on your ass
right and I've learned metaphysically
there's laws the universe as long as I'm
good and try to be judged and try to be
honest and it is humble yeah and I try
to tell the truth I get hit but whoever
hits me I mean like it's bad man yeah
going online uh without expressvpn is
like leaving your kids with the nearest
stranger while using the restroom
expressvpn they scramble the IP address
the government's uh I can't get yeah but
maybe you know they can but the
corporate people can't get you
um expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between you and your device and
the internet so that hackers can't steal
your data hackers can make some serious
cash selling personal information on the
dark web experience VPN has made it
easier than ever to keep your
information safe just fire up the app
click one button and you're instantly
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices like laptops phones tablets uh
so you can stay secure on the go secure
your online data today at expressvpn.com
Tim Dillon and get three months free
three [__] months free that's
expressvpi expressvpn.com Tim Dylan
expressvpn.com you probably need more
than expressvp you have the NSA is
straight you know I don't know if it's
well expressvpn do it for you maybe I
will it's not that it was feeling bad
it's right close your door at night you
need to be doing this regardless because
there's all these corrupt systems
like I've had people I don't want to get
into it because it's like Voodoo but
it's real I've had people mess with me
like that my car wrecks like a week
right I mean it's like I'm like hey you
need to watch out you know because it's
like I'm for real and the thing is
anybody that's lived long enough knows
this is there's real loss man yeah like
a video game has laws this thing has
lost I'm not threatening anybody I'm
saying you mess with me or anybody who's
righteous you're you're you're you're
grabbing a high-powered line man yeah
you're sticking your dick in a
light-sided yeah for sure well I hope
that I hope by having you on here I get
some of that protection from you I hope
it I hope it bounces off I'm very humble
about it but I've learned it's real yeah
well here's what is in but it's not even
protection it's that if they're gonna
hit you they got to be willing to get 10
times back right like they're like it's
a black study black magic I'm even into
magic but it's like a metaphysical
example right in Black Magic a black
magic practitioner can do something bad
right but they're going to get 10 times
back that's right so are you willing to
freaking do that yes so we have all this
information we have it I identify this
is a vitamin stick yeah not as a
cancerous thing this is identify as a
woman I can two men could have a baby
that's made by Pfizer What I think
they're good for you yeah but I think
the people effective yeah people don't
these are things people don't know about
you is that you're fun you're fun
because you're a guy that deeply
believes things and if you're wrong
you'll admit you're wrong I've been
wrong and you'll move on but I was never
wrong for a place of lying that's right
you believe things you go hey you know
but
so much stuff has come out I've watched
clips of you talking about George W bush
before he was going to be president and
what they were going to do I've
obviously you talk about 9 11. I see you
talk about uh the WTO the World Trade
Commission like you are you walk a beat
that very few people do in America
almost nobody does and it's got to take
a toll on you a little bit well why
can't I meet you and you're you're a fun
guy you love comedians comedians love to
hang out with you so you're one of these
people you can enjoy yourself
even though you know you're you're
really putting yourself out there
all the time in a bunch of different
ways well I was completely honest when I
was like in one of like eight
depositions in the whole lawsuits
against me and
I was completely honest with them just
like I was honest with Joe yeah on on
his show like one of the podcasts before
last like four years ago
I'm like I got to a point like five six
years ago where I I wouldn't even call
The psychosis I said it's almost like a
psychosis where if I've been lied to you
so much I just got lazy and I said it's
all [__] right and so then I would
just say I don't believe any of it you
can't do that you got to still analyze
each piece they went oh oh he's trying
to do an insanity place that doesn't
happen in civil cases right I was being
honest like
like I knew Joe Rogan 25 years ago I
knew Joe was into all the stuff before I
was I know he's probably the most
cunning smart person I know a great guy
a huge yard I got really mad at him five
years ago because he was suddenly Towing
the line and kind of buying the system
with his own delusion so I got really
pissed at him he later admitted I was
right and apologized but I was more
wrong than he was so like he was kind of
a little bit wrong and I went after him
and went too far and he admitted that
for now look at him he's total anti-new
World Order he's going against their
whole system so it's the same process
but I did get to a point where it didn't
matter what it was I thought it was
staged uh and and so I said those things
about other events and things I really
meant that so they go oh you admit
you're crazy yeah I am crazy as in if
the whole world's insane
and then that makes somebody that's not
insane crazy fine I'm crazy right right
Hey listen at the end of the day it's
like you know there are people that will
never
forgive you or they'll never look at
your whole history of work but then
there are people that'll go this
motherfucker's been out there 30 [__]
years
he's been talking about real [__] for a
very long time and there's so much of it
that he's been right about you you
should get you know the benefit of the
doubt that's what they do is they cherry
pick yeah and they take things out of
context but that's fine
I'm trying to stop World War III yeah
I'm trying to stop it which they want
now with the Ukraine they want it with
Russia they want it like they want their
they seem to be ratcheting up tensions
with China
it does seem to be very weird to see or
basically at war with China we have a
language that's being used I mean I
remember all these articles and then you
know New York Times coming out like can
we survive a nuclear war maybe it would
be good and New York Times in New York
they're running TV ads about hey there's
nuclear Awards not maybe I'll just tune
into your local app right we're not
gonna have an app and I'm glad you went
there just download yeah because we were
about to go on your show today yeah and
I said Dylan can we not really talk
about me and you said you said enough to
January 6 first but I really think Alex
Jones doesn't matter let's move to World
War III yeah let's because I'm not
trying to direct your interview no no
I'm I'm with you I agree with you seeing
what's happening right now is crazy
yes and in all the main actuaries and
all the real war planners say nuclear
war is becoming a probability I don't
like that yeah that'll really mess up uh
Maya you're telling people to kind of
like relax and enjoy it like hey not a
big deal a couple of nukes they call
them tactical nukes they're small you
won't even notice it don't worry about
it hey it might be a good thing and this
is terrifying if you pay attention to
this because tax always lead to full-on
oh for sure for sure and what they're
doing is that when you arm
the Ukraine with all NATO weapons Russia
is essentially fighting NATO you might
Putin I don't think he's a good guy and
there's U.S soldiers there too yeah of
course I don't support his invasion I
understand I understand why he did it
when I looked at what someone like him
would do yeah if the U.S yeah if the U.S
on the Mexican Board of the Russians yes
had all these troops and weapons we'd
attack them yes so with the real politic
of the situation you have to step back
and go they're very complicated they had
a CIA coup they installed zelinski this
is it's very strange our president's
crackhead son has a sweetheart job with
an energy company in the Ukraine we're
now funding the Ukraine like a lot of
coincidences
um but from the beginning I was like we
should push for an agreement and we
should push for peace and we should push
for Less death and they have said to
zelinski don't negotiate ratchet up
tensions we're gonna give you missiles
we're gonna give you all the Weaponry
you want we're gonna give you a crazy
amount of money even when we have
tremendous problems here at home and I
don't know and they're trying to bleed
rush or dry with this war that's right
it's the Cold War again they want to
bleed rush or dry and Russia is a
nuclear superpower not an economic
superpower or even really maybe a
military superpower but they have more
nukes than anybody else and that's
really my message to the left and the
right everybody else I don't want to be
a partisan person I don't want to fight
with you I just want to live I've got
children right we are in a hot war with
Russia and it's escalating in the
nuclear war and absolutely it just needs
to stop it so okay just stop the nuclear
war
that's over asking for the children
absolutely because we could talk about
January 6 and let's check people up and
that's all important why do they want
this Alex why do they walk right up to
nuclear war is it money
is it the fact that our economy is based
on the military-industrial complex just
constantly
you know printing money paying
themselves you know why will they risk
what seems to people like such a huge
disaster well you just said it the
financial system and the Ponzi scheme is
coming to an end it's coming to an end
so it can't like uber and all this gig
economy [__] is not doing it and they're
probably starting to realize that
they're like yeah we told people like
you used to have jobs now you work for
Postmates isn't it great isn't it the
same it's not people are angry and now
you're kind of seeing they're like oh we
need to go back to our original business
War exactly war is Health estate and so
it's a distraction for the vertical
integration the consolidation the crime
all of it that's what tyrants always do
when they're in trouble is they expand a
war except you can't do that enough as a
nuclear weapons right and so just what
six months ago there's that famous clip
maybe your crew can queue it up heck
let's see who can find it boys well
let's queue up the club of Biden saying
six months ago you can't put Abram's
tanks in a in in in Ukraine that'll lead
to nuclear war up the threat escalation
ladder but then he did it right and now
they're training F-16 pilots and now
what are they gonna do with him he he
seems to be in a state of cognitive
decline
I mean I think that's emblematic I mean
settlement they love that fetterman
can't even show up he hasn't been seen
in in five weeks yes and so now somebody
else votes for him right so I think
that's the model I think it's like a
brain a jar I think he'll probably run
again they'll steal the election he'll
win again and maybe in 100 years no
one's even seen Biden he's like well the
president's Biden they'll have some you
know Chuck E cheese animatronic thing no
I mean
[Music]
ancient times they called it a dog king
or Caligula or was it uh was it Caligula
or was it uh one of the Roman emperors
uh married his horse okay and people
said that was just insane no it was
insulting the Senate and he made the
horse uh the the the the the region or
the consulate or the president of the
Senate right so so God it's not Caligula
I'm about to think of it Nero no it was
Caligula okay it wasn't Iran yeah so
look up what Roman emperor made his
horse the head of the Senate he also
married the horse and the point is is
that
this has happened over and over again
it's an insult saying you're so pathetic
you're so ridiculous I'm gonna make the
horse that so when you've got a
fetterman that can't talk it hasn't been
seen in five weeks yeah when you got a
Biden Who falls down the stairs every
time he walks it's all a joke on us so
tomorrow I said we had to realize that's
not our leader that's a puppet that's
done to get us to accept new standards
in fact I'm told your crew here on the
Tim Dillon show found the club here's
Biden six seven months ago saying we
cannot send Abrams Tanks to Ukraine
dear the idea that we're going to send
in offensive equipment and have planes
and tanks and trains uh going in with
American pilots and American Crews
just understand and don't kid yourself
no matter what you all say that's called
World War III
so in the calculus Tim Dillon what
changed in the last six seven months and
now it's wonderful
yeah I mean I guess people sat him down
or he was already sitting down and they
said listen we're changing our posture
you know we're going to ratchet up these
tensions we're going to arm the Ukraine
they can maybe win this thing and we can
bleed Russia out I'm gonna change your
camera shot it's driving me crazy yeah
it's your crew's fault keep going keep
going I agree with you
um but I think that's what that's what's
happened and propaganda works really
well we're very good at it as a country
so if people believe that it's morally
right and correct to divert billions of
dollars from the needs of U.S citizens
to ukrainians even though they are going
through something horrible and tragic if
people believe that's a moral correct a
morally correct position and they have
certitude and the people in power are
telling them this is the right thing to
do
we all know how powerful that is because
a lot of you know people want to do the
right thing they want to feel like they
are supporting causes that are just I'm
sure the Ukraine cause is just in the
sense that they don't want Russians with
the Russians there's so many beefs
there's so much [__] going on but the
point of just being used as a proxy we
don't really have a national security
interest in that war we have a financial
interest in it see that's the camera
shot that's a little crooked
I'm obsessing over this see I want
things to be right too I I agree with
you is that Jim is that camera is this
January 6th who are these people
oh I got it okay I'm fine gotcha it's
all live see I'm directing yourself live
I'm being mean to your crib we're
looking at the people here who are they
do we trust them are they agent
provocateurs are they sex operators from
the CIA we don't know but like seriously
you have a lot of Courage had me on
because they don't want this hurt they
don't want this discussed I'm just here
like everybody else trying to figure
this out yeah and
the issue is every analyst every Brand
Corporation Pentagon says the the path
we're on it's like a car driving towards
a cliff yeah we were a mile away from
the cliff now we're a quarter mile from
the cliff and if we keep driving we're
gonna drive off the Grand Canyon and
then the people right in the media are
writing articles going the cliff is good
Don't Fear The Cliff the cliff is
actually good so that's what I noticed
about yeah you know six months right
right six months ago there was a big
change where people started saying like
no no no no we cannot abandon this cause
we need to do everything in our power to
defeat Russia the goal was originally
peace now it's to defeat Russia that's a
different goal tactically it's a
different goal exactly and the Russians
are like oh you killed 200 000 Russians
yeah and they're doubling down that's
what Russians do right so it's on their
doorstep it needs to stop even Henry
Kissinger three months ago is like this
will cause nuclear war we gotta have a
peace deal now he's like remove Putin
you have the new Ukrainian defense
minister a month ago say we're going to
invade Russia and take over and put
tanks in Moscow right
I mean so so I'm not pro-russia I've
never been to Russia uh
it it's insane and I don't even know how
to deal with this because you have all
these leftists that used to be anti-war
and so was I now they love it they love
the prospects
well yeah ever since the the Russian
gate thing with Trump which turned out
to be not true there was this idea that
Russia we needed some type of conflict
with Russia and it was crazy CDC
uh boss head boss testified at a
congressional inquiry yes and they said
this is what we call the Timberland show
final episode on YouTube so we hope you
all enjoy this is the final episode here
on YouTube before because in America
you're not allowed to show a C-SPAN Club
yeah it's wild too you showed me these
clips earlier before we went on air yeah
uh you've got uh you you 've got that
former head of the CDC
uh director Redfield saying it was gain
of function and they were flying and
they covered it up and he's not part of
it he's literally turning States
evidence and I don't think you should
show this to him blue chill
the Dick's got to work it's the summer
or the spring I take it not even for sex
I just like to wake up in the middle of
the night and look at it and then go
back to bed blue chill I mean you know
it's great
um we have a special deal for our list
we know what Bluetooth I don't have to
explain this every week for five years
but we know what the [__] Bluetooth does
and we're happy they spawn to the show
and if you have that issue and you enjoy
the show get blue I don't need to tell
you what Bluetooth we not it's you chew
it your dick gets hard that's what
Bluetooth is everyone knows what
Bluetooth is we've got a special deal
for our listeners try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code TD at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
bluetooth.com promo code TD to receive
your first month free that's
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast and
they ship it to the door nobody knows
what it is it's discreet everybody loves
it you know what it is just get the get
the [__] Bluetooth you know what it
is I know well no no no no no no but
what about the people that want to buy
athletic greens we need the views
we need the views [__] Bluetooth
dick pills we need the views
by the way I love the media saying Jones
sells fake dick pills what's the word I
will assure you our dick pills work they
work and what's the worst thing that
could happen Michael Hastings or you
know hey
whatever you gotta do it we gotta do it
there's nothing more 20 23 than Dying
For The View count so please show the
CDC clip yeah okay we got a couple of
these which one do you want we've got uh
the damning one the one that gets us
killed clip shot says viewers this is
the head of the CDC yes testifying and
then we've got a Matt Tybee being
attacked for Joe Rogan okay let's do
head of CDC first y'all do that here's
there's that of the CDC
one other path of questioning for you Dr
Ripple proponents of This research claim
it may result in vaccines or maybe even
stop a pandemic
Dr Redfield has gained a function
created any life-saving vaccines or
Therapeutics to your knowledge
not to my knowledge has gain of function
stopped a pandemic to in your opinion
you know in the contrary I think it
probably caused the greatest pandemic
our world has seen do you find any
tangible benefits uh to gain a function
research at this time
I personally don't but I do want to
stress I think the men and women that
supported
are people of good faith because they
truly believe it's going to lead to a
potential benefit I disagree with that
assessment gain of function research is
let's make scary viruses even scarier
let's get the government to give us more
money and increase the endowments and
the budget and he just said gain a
function caused the cover to be a living
right he just said that and he goes on
and this by the way this is not a crank
this is not somebody we found on 6th
Street in Austin which is lovely this
time of year this is the ex head of the
Center for Disease Control yeah but I
think fact Checkers say we shouldn't air
this well and by the way we got more
clubs because I know you show them to me
yes we have more a bunch of other clubs
where he went through how he knew it was
going to function he knew it was a
weapon but they wouldn't let him say
anything excluded him from the meetings
so let's put those on too because like
if we're gonna go out let's go out and
style okay well let me look up which
calyps those were from your list gain of
function stuff is now coming out I
remember in the old day is when you'd be
kicked off social media for saying that
stuff but now it's starting to come out
and people are basically I think
becoming more aware of the fact that
this is not uh oh
um a naturally occurring virus it was
manipulated genetically in a lab it was
manipulated for a reason and then it
might have leaked someone might have
leaked it I don't know that anyone's
gone that far yet but I think it's
becoming a widely established belief
that this idea that it was a bat
that you know somebody ate a bat in the
soup
it was about fauci's god let's play the
evil C-SPAN Club of a man that needs to
be arrested the former advocacy who does
he think he is he's a shut up let's play
Club two Dr Robert Redfield testifies on
three unusual events in the Wuhan lab in
September 2019 before they released it
listen to this
bad person here it is that I will say if
you go back and look it's Declassified
now and I'm sure you all have your
classified briefings but the
Declassified information now in
September of 2019 three things happened
in that lab
one is they deleted the sequences
was highly irregular researchers don't
usually like to do that second thing
they did was they changed the command
and control of the lab from the civilian
control to the military control
highly unusual and I've been involved in
doing your slabs when I was in the
military and the third things they did
which I think is really telling is they
led a contractor redo the ventilation
system in that Laboratory
so I think clearly there was strong
evidence that there was a significant
event that happened in that laboratory
in September it's now been Declassified
you can read it I'm sure there's more
classified information around so a
significant event no this is just
information I agree with you tonight
yeah
this is evil yeah okay but there's a
worse clip I mean just listen to this
horrible person uh here is uh he's just
doing it for clout
yeah dude acts out of the CDC is just
trying he he just wants clout yeah he's
not turning against the whole system I
have the quotes here that's right where
he says he wants to be a hybrid test
listen to these quotes listen to this
horrible person Redfield explains his
rationality there's several suspicious
events occurred at the Wulan Institute
of Urology in the months proceeding so
we just played that club but let's play
a clip here
let's play the clip here of uh clip six
MTG talks the former CDC director Robert
Redfield reveals covid-19 virus was
likely created by gain of function
research which he admits was going on
which faucy says it wasn't even though
in the files he calls it gain of
function which is illegal by the way
it's the death penalty yeah here it is
Dr Redfield did you agree in your
opinion with Dr Anderson's assessment at
the time that this virus did look
engineered
I was concerned because of the presence
of the fury and cleavage site that we've
talked about and I think it's important
to understand what that cleavage site
does
that cleavage site totally changes the
orientation of The Binding domain of
covid so it now which could not see the
H2 receptor which is the human receptor
it totally changes the orientation now
so it has high affinity for a human
receptor so that fear in clevisite
bothered me it didn't seem that it
belonged there and then when you look at
the sequences that it used it's beyond
the committee but I know many of you
have looked into it the sequences that
they used in those 12 nucleotides for
arginine where the Arginine sequences
nucleotide triplet that are coded for
the human arginine so why did this virus
have the Arginine sequences for human
they're not bad it was very
disconcerting to me it looked like this
virus was engineered was this odd it's a
billion years ago is this something that
would be in line with gain of function
research
usually she goes to the wild but this
she actually seems like on target you
know she can get a little nuts but this
seems like she got the glasses she's
like okay she's in the zone
um yeah it's a problem we cooked it up
Us in China was it was it a joint effort
was it a please let me know it's a
little bit of us it wasn't just China
right as much as I hate the Communist
Chinese who are the most evil thing on
earth right uh it's a total setup about
he talks about that in another club yeah
there's articles in Nature and Science
in 2015 when good scientists win why is
the federal government weaponizing
coronavirus with a gain of function
using HIV Spike protein which is the
cleavage point it's like that's the horn
or the the Rhino horn it's what plugs
into the cells
and so
he goes through all of that in the clip
that this obviously had to be done here
because it was done here in 2015 it was
a huge Scandal so then Western money
Bill Gates Peter does it they talk about
the hearing this is not my opinion for
YouTube I mean you play the clips they
move it to Wuhan
so there's plausible deniability so
obviously the Chinese people traded our
government they're involved but they
allowed to be taken there to do illegal
stuff in a third-party country right
because when they're doing in Ukraine
and in in the UK and other places now
all of this may be true but the
vaccine's still good right
absolutely I mean let's just come out
and say at least that's good it's safe
and effect it is and you should get as
much of it as you can
uh well actually people should research
that they said it was 99 effective the
96 effective 95 effective than 67
effective and 45 effective and now the
new studies uh are that within six
months you have a lower immunity and a
higher rate of infection sickness and
death yeah but but I mean listen I still
think you should take it I'm a big
Pfizer nice to go and get it you know
what I mean let's be honest there's too
many people there's a lot of people I
think you should give it to your
children yeah
double boost them right and you know
those little guys they're eating too
much yeah I mean seriously well who's
gonna lie we're all sick of these loud
ass kids yeah look it's a legal way to
get rid of them now do you think because
listen it seems like it's somewhat of an
ineffective way it's a legal way to get
rid of their sickness which is being
alive right right
I feel like it's in it it's a I feel
like it's an ineffective way to
depopulate the Earth well what I do
think is that this was an opportunity
for a company to make a trillion dollars
maybe every year at infinim
um no but I agree but then why did they
bring something out
that was so wonderful I mean right I
mean you did so much good I mean the
point is you take this shot you get 10
years on your life right by the way
that's a joke folks the point is we're
still at a point where you're not
supposed to talk about this remember
we're Vindicated that it came out of the
lab we're Vindicated that it's not
working we're vindicate all all this
stuff so you know imagine the sensor is
watching us feeling all powerful you're
being attacked by it too dumbasses
athletic greens no but I agree uh well
they do they do say that vitamins are
key it's good
you gotta take the [__]
I take athletic you have a vitamin in
your hand right now you gave me an
athletic green enema this morning yes we
have to it's more effective now all of
this stuff coming out you put in a
turkey baster yes of course well yeah
you have to we had we had to put you in
stir ups and treat you like a pregnant
woman which you are because everyone's
everything actually I identify as a
woman yes and this are you doing
anything at South by Southwest I have no
I'm just here I mean that would be a
great place to get married you know in
let's see if Google would let us use
their like tent I think we should do a
mock marriage yeah at the Google tent
but it should be a polyamory yeah you
and I should Roseanne oh what's the
fourth thing quad Emory I don't know we
should all marry a Pfizer's shot I don't
know what the fourth thing is find a
fifth grade
yeah remember that Stephen Colbert yeah
really cringe thing with the dancing
dancing
syringes we should marry a dancing Saran
I'm serious yeah what do you think does
this ever
collapse maybe not I used to think it
would collapse under its own weight now
will it collapse under its own absurdity
you're just talking about dancing
syringes lying in your face the most
insane things we've ever seen the most
cringe examples of and then using social
media if you don't agree with a lie
right you're gonna be censored yeah I
think like the Soviet Union it's just
gonna die of its own absurdity because
the operatives in the system they've had
over the last two years it's been
reported over 10 000 FBI what's the
lawyers of Congress right it all gets
hidden they all get attacked but that
tells you like I don't want to like
worship the FBI obviously they're not
the enemy it's an agency that's captured
I'm on an airplane and and a radical
Islamic whoever hijacks it I don't blame
the airline like that's a real pilot
right so I mean we're on a hijack
country the agencies have been hijacked
and I'm just saying can we please get
off this thing and and so I I want to
reach out to the agencies and reach out
to the corporations and reach out to
people and say listen this is kind of
dangerous yeah can we just stop now can
we just stop it calm it down yeah I I
I'm telling you I I'm shocked at the
amount of people
that for whatever reason are still
buying a lot against vitamins well you
identify this as a vitamin stick Vapor
stick yeah but
identify this as eternal life do you
think are you gonna my pronouns is
nicotine yes are you are you saying this
isn't good for me no it's I think it's
phenomenal for you it's it's his you're
validating me I'm validating him you're
not being nicophobic I'm not being
nicophobic boy we got to be careful with
that word but here's what I will say
um we just calling the term yes
nickaphobic I'm sure Susan which Nick is
loving this I
um she just lost her job did she I don't
pay attention who's doing it now Meghan
Markle probably yeah it's the spot did
you love the South Park on them well
it's great you know I have a bit about
it on stage now um it's absurd it's
insane and we're made to we need a dose
of victimhood all the time no matter oh
you poor Royals horrible oh my gosh
looks horrible because what it does it
makes it demoralizes people and that's
where they seem to kind of want they
want people demoralized so those people
don't really have to you know proceed in
a way that would ever result in these
people losing any power at all I totally
agree and the final sponsor
greedypossum.com greedy possum what's
greedy pot tones greedy possum is a
weapons system for the Martians were
they selling uh mind control devices
well I like this a lot
greenypawson.com infowars.com band.video
by the way I've not looked up
greedyposum.com is that even a website
please we could edit it out if it's a
problem Alex Jones
the king of Austin Texas is it Joe Rogan
to you it might be you I think it's Joe
well
I'm going to say to you for history
sounds like a planet and a bigger thing
Eclipse it's fine I know all right Joe's
bigger than all shows well you know
Joe's telling the truth so it's kind of
good to just sit back you kind of that's
what you expect like you causing
influence yeah and people wake up and
then big things happen you got to kind
of learn to go away well it's gonna be
fun the comedy club's open thank you so
much for letting me do this I appreciate
it uh the second part of the episode is
out on patreon you were you were really
an amazing eloquent person who has
looked into this [__] for many many
years and people that think they know
you should probably look into your stuff
and I don't know we're married I have no
idea that we're married but they will
because Bill Gates at South by Southwest
is going to give us we're renewing our
vows we should get married on TV if we
can get married at South by Southwest
I'll absolutely come
um we're getting married Joe will be the
priest you hear that CAA we're getting
married good night